first and foremost i wanted to say i
love the show i've seen the first
episode and i thought it was lovely i
want to know describe the show uh for
fans who may not understand what it is
or be familiar with the books it kind of
falls in the middle between like a game
of thrones and a lot of lord of rings i
mean it's just this
character rich
pickup keep going
here
character rich
epic based on 14 books written by the
amazing robert jordan that paul is the
journey of this amazing group of women
called i sedi
who uh have these who can access this
power call the one power from the true
source
i play lan who is the awarder to my rain
mrosman's character and we have this
amazing con
action called bond and we're on this
journey we're on this journey to find um
a dragon reborn who's a character who um
everybody knows that this cataclysmic
massive event called the last battle is
coming i didn't choose this path but i
will follow it
where next the two rivers
the old blood runs deep in those
mountains
let's hope it's prepared them for what's
coming
and as a force
of evil in the world the dark one who is
imprisoned by the creator the force of
good and
the dark ones um
the dark one is escaping his prison when
he's going to escape no one knows but
what is coming is the last battle and
our mission is to present the dragon
reborn we don't know who the dragon
reborn is we're meant to present the
dragon reborn
he has to appear before the dark one by
the last battle at the last battle and
um
and so we've got a kind of massive job
on our hands um and
fervor and determination to carry it
through and i think you know
in in the midst of that you've got
people who mistrust us you've got people
trying to stop us you've got people with
different agendas you've got people
trying to as always you know as
you know what's interesting about any
plan is all the attempts to foil it um
so it's a very beautiful world it's got
characters that clearly the fans of the
books have loved for years you know the
the letters and the things that we've
read online and fans everybody has a
different character that they read
themselves into you know we've got a
very unusual fantasy we've got all these
strong women and i've had you know
correspondences from male fans who said
that you know these women have been role
models for them and some of the guys
have been role models for women so it's
this wonderful kind of urban flow and we
are just rambling at this point can you
step into it no i wanted to listen let
this go i didn't know where it was going
to end up i love it i know it's late
i'll i'll push us through here um you
guys started work in prague in 2019
daniel you kind of touched on this a
little bit what's been uh the most
interesting thing about kind of being in
the czech republic and stuff for this
well one of the things is that we've all
relocated we've all believed in this
show enough to relocate to leave our
loved ones and families and friends well
i mean i've brought my family with with
me but you know i've i've put my
children in school in prague i mean it's
a proper big move um
and
you know but i'm away from all my
friends and everything i know in london
and similarly with daniel and and zoe
and maddie and josh nobody is is at home
and and i think that one thing that's
does is bring the whole cast way closer
together so then at the core of this
show you've got a cast that really loves
each other and you feel that in the show
and i think that's what audiences will
be able to get behind because we really
are
close and we
fully believe in the show because we
believed enough in it to kind of
open and
get behind it and move country for it
yeah at the core of it these these
characters are going on this incredible
journey together and it feels like we're
doing the exact same thing as a cast
um yeah and prague as a city is
absolutely gorgeous and and so rich and
full of life and
and there's so much beauty and it lends
itself to kind of being in that world at
all times which as an actor is all you
could ask for you know and our sets are
phenomenal we've gotten craftsmen who
can make and you know i mean build sets
bigger and faster than i've known
anywhere else in the world actually um
so we there's never a world there's
never a scene in the series that isn't
at least partially built for us there's
nothing that's left entirely to our
imaginations we've got i mean i think
the fans of the book would just flip if
we could invite them to do a studio tour
which of course has been impossible for
anyone
during the all the covered restrictions
but it
you know we're so proud of our sets they
really are no they're beautiful and the
wardrobe and the makeup and the whole uh
environment that's being created there i
mean it's fascinating to look at
visually it's amazing daniel i want to
ask you about
we kind of talked about this for a
second earlier but we i've seen you with
guns and i've seen you did you have to
learn any new skills for this right
you're wielding axes and spears and
swords and i don't know what else but
talk on that i mean lan is a master
swordsman he's really really talented so
i mean i had some pretty big
shoes to fill i guess you would say um
i'd worked with size before for the
double side so i could kind of as far as
weapons went but i never worked with
with the sword like this so it was it
was a process a learning process um some
of the footwork was the same with some
of the previous practices i'd been
involved with if we do not stop the dark
one now
the whole world will burn
i can't allow it
and roseman you have i mean these powers
that are incredible with this magic
what's i mean what's most fun about
toying in that world you know you do you
do this thing in the in the hot tub and
the water's hot and i'm like how very
useful this magic is i know it would i
could have used it today when i had a
freezing cold shower it's funny you know
they don't really use it for the boring
stuff i mean lorraine is very
disciplined in her use of the one pound
she really saves it for the big stuff i
mean she's a bit annoyed with lan asking
her to heat up the bathroom right you
know that's not it's a bit sort of you
know beneath her she's she's quite sort
of stoic and
in terms of not really asking for too
many creature comforts but um
lan however you know he learns we've got
another scene that we've just come up
with sort of that i've just been sort of
carrying water buckets for sort of miles
across the italian countryside for him
to have a sort of
shower and basically sorry that's an
episode two season two thing i can't
talk about that um
the one power is uh
yeah it was very exciting because robert
jordan writes about it so vividly he it
it sort of he writes about it as this
kind of intoxicating feeling when you
channel that it's um
it's it's electrifying and also toxic so
it's this combination of deliciousness
and danger and so to kind of
explore that and to feel it i mean i
knew it would be enhanced with visual
effects but to kind of cue the visual
effects by
by really embodying it that was a very
exciting opportunity
[Music]
you